and you are not my brother I'm not your
brother all the stuff we've been through
rush hour one rush hour two
[Music]
we'd love to see that we would love to
see that Jack
Jack we'd like to see that we'd like to
see that now Jack we'd love to see that
wouldn't we love to see that his name is
Lee God damn it Lee we would love to see
that
cheers
a freeze that's right Lee for the last
three years I've studied the ancient
teaching of booty ever a booty
we need to talk get her relax maybe we
can open up a bottle of wine and some of
the champagne
maybe open up oh
let's relax maybe open the wine in the
midi bar yeah I'm better than Chris
Tucker yeah fire him 50 million dollars
do you think you got Kelsey Clinton
50 million dollars so you think you got
Kelsey
50 million dollars do you think you got
Chelsea is it Chelsea cut kiss you know
all that other stuff but you don't know
his name
fan
people tell me [ __ ]
what's wrong with you
man
50 million dollars do you think you got
Chelsea Carter 50 million dollars who
you think you got Chelsea Grandma
Chelsea 50 million dollars who you think
you got Chelsea Clinton give me 200
[ __ ]
oh
my God
I'm sick of you Kenji you been trying to
kill us ever since it started this damn
movie
I like the one with a locker room scene
what I like the one with a prison scene
I like the one with the shower scene I
like the ones with a white girl I'm into
feet I like the one with the horses
what's that mean my daddy wants to cut
catch a bullet caught caught your bullet
coach my daddy want to caught a bullet
but he's a bare hand no [ __ ]
I like when we're hairy woman what's
wrong with you I don't know but right
now teach me that
so tell me something about the about
saying
who you say
why you ask somebody along well yeah
something I don't know who cares damn
he ain't gonna be in rush hour three
culture
priceless
pieces of Chinese
why didn't you tell me about this man
I told you already no you didn't what do
you say I did what I did
what do this mean that means you go this
way you you
that means you go this way that means I
go this way you go this way speak
English what do you say
laughs
what's going on in there
I believe your father
wasting his life
wake me in an hour man then I'll take
over from there
cutter they have something I have to
tell you someone's phone huh
answer the phone first answer the phone
bro
keep rolling yeah
answer the phone
phone is that
I'm gonna get it
okay you know right now nobody said
that's my phone
[Laughter]
you're right man let's go tell them
I don't have nothing to do with this all
I did was got a car and I was the back
of Lee up telepod I need to see you
again
you understand what I'm saying I
understand okay see anything goes wrong
you busting that act like you had lap
you cannot speak English all the
evidence disappear can't resigned and
the evidence was never seeking
all the evidence
all the evidence
all the evidence
or the f
all the evidence
all the evidence disappears
I kill myself
what happened why are you so happy my
father already died may I offer you some
peanuts she she
[Laughter]
I like to buy you a new laptop it's no
problem yes it is a problem because I
didn't have no business doing it I you
know I didn't even know who he really
was because Lee didn't tell me who you
really works if I know I must excuse
myself
I want to never mess with you
can I hang out with you the rest of the
trip because I think me and you will
really like each other I'm not hanging
out no more relief please not my friend
okay Chris Tucker
Jackie again he was in an orphanage you
told me your father was a cop it was
but they taught me
yeah talk to me
orphanage
so you want to tell me how in the world
I get into the U.S Smith to do the
perfect benefit one more time so you
want to tell me how in the world I get
into the U.S meant to use the prince
prices oh you want to tell us how in the
world they break into the duck
what happened
when they taught me when what was 11.
[Music]
ah
yeah
[Music]
medicine I always want to go to Sequim
I always dreamed to square Martin
feel me how in the world are getting
you want to tell us how in the world
they get into the U.S meant to use the
precises
[Laughter]
I always want to go to myself
now I'm gone now I'm nervous every God
and I'm nervous
Mount Juno we're here to see Jon vinay
Jones
BF
bonjour we here to see Joan vs so our
eyes a little droopy now and she so
she's working for El Loco
I'm sorry it's El Pollo Loco so now she
works at El Loco yeah
no ass BS BF BS
what right here
we have bonjour we here to see Joan vs
hello Laura Poco uh el poco loco el loco
poco so so she works
[Music]
action
I said I don't want trouble
almost forgot my dialogue